all right we got beautiful weather to
get out make some moves today and uh
please be drinking a lot of h2o uh the
the north winds have really dried out
the air and it really is uh you can
notice the difference immediately so we
had all that moisture in the air last
week and that really felt so good and
then those north winds come in dry
everything out
really scrub the air make it all clean
so we've had beautiful views
but it is really dry out there dew
points are only in the teens this
morning temperatures in the 40s mostly a
couple of spots like nellis seven hills
in the 30s red rocks in the mid 30s
upper 30s up there at kyle canyon so we
get another day to relax minus the winds
but they are coming back pretty soon 18
up in cedar city 20s in caliani 10 in
ely we've got 28 indian springs mid 30s
for prompt and mesquite 42 in boulder
city 55 in laughlin so our monday looks
like this 65 degrees lots of sunshine
we're very close to that sunrise now it
takes a couple of extra minutes because
of our mountains
6 47 officially the sunrise and the
sunset so close to 5 o'clock it sets
sooner than that because of the
mountains on the other side all right so
we've got a little snow still coming
into the northern plains the upper
midwest still very very cold rain has
ended for seattle for the moment for the
time being thank goodness i'm sure
they're happy about that snow continues
across the great lakes the ohio valley
look at these 20s cincinnati nashville
barely above freezing and raleigh durham
right there at 33 degrees 39 for atlanta
that snow is going to make its way to
the east coast today it's not a lot of
it it's not a lot of measurement but
there will be some high pressure over
the west delivering good sunshine for us
but another system rounding over that
ridge tomorrow is what's going to bring
the north winds back mid 60s today
beautiful getting out and walking
weather take a bike ride take an
extended walk with the dog really good
for you that vitamin d is so good for
your immune system breezy north winds
tomorrow and those could get up 25 30
miles an hour we cool off behind that
system upper 50s on wednesday and then a
few high clouds to finish the week
friday into saturday and look at those
upper 60s to finish the month of january